the Joe Rogan experience well you know
we live in the times where everyone's
saying is right-wing so so it let it be
so high don't know well if you're not as
progressive as humanly possible you're
alright well yeah exactly pretty much
I've seen all sorts of titles levied on
to everybody including including
yourself so yeah for people don't know
zoobi won the World Championships and
women's powerlifting you identified as a
woman for a brief period of time yeah
nine second lift it's all you have to do
yeah I mean this is the world we live in
dude that that thing blew the internet
off but it's crazy I'm saying how far it
went mad yeah I know I saw that people
there it is let's yeah yes I identify as
a woman whilst lifting the weight don't
be a bigot
you know I think I think when you first
talked about that I had like 40,000
followers it's now well over 100 and 115
and when I posted it I had 15,000
followers so I've gained 100 and I've
gained like yeah like 105 thousand five
thousand followers it worked a video
congratulations yeah thanks man really
does highlight how preposterous
these new world rules that we have
regarding gender but to their credit the
US powerlifting Federation I believe
that's the name of the organization they
just banned transgender women from
competing okay they just said out rap
just flat there's enough enough of that
I think if you want to compete I don't
think there's anything wrong with
transgender women competing but I think
they should compete against transgender
women just like how we have men compete
against men and we have women compete
against women let's have transgender
women compete against transgender women
let's not deny science and biology yes
to make people feel better and just to
support some strange progressive
ideology yeah I think if they if the
goal is that's why I think the goal is
more about it's more ideologically
driven then I think it is actual
inclusion driven because if it's just
about inclusion then yeah you can either
just have an open category like most
men's categories already are they're not
actually restricted to men it's just you
know the best of the best so anyone can
do this so either that or if there are
enough athletes in whatever the give
Sporto competition is then yeah you can
just have a different a different
category and that way everyone can be
included without stepping on the feet of
half the population that's a bold move
by the men say anybody can be in here
that's how it is in pool you know men
can't compete in the women's division of
pool but women can compete in the men's
division yeah it's the same in most
sports most people aren't aware that
most people think that they're they have
specific restriction saying only men can
do them but that's actually quite rare
well there's a lot of successful female
to male athletes working females
transition to males and dominate male
sports okay
I made it up what is this what is going
on well have you seen this there's a
soccer player's wants to be in the NFL
as a kicker
Khurshid there's a video of her doing a
place kick of a 55 yard or yard field
goal recently that's incredible that's
really far no one coming out or anything
was just like in practice but she nailed
it which is pretty far yes well can you
tackle kickers they can get hit yeah
they're not during the actual play of
the kick they're not supposed to be
touched but for sure they're in the play
of the field so mmm well that's [ __ ]
up that's not good that's where the
problem is Carla love yeah yeah but stop
yeah it's a bad idea